alkohol gerade hier so was ist eine
extrem böse sache ist was wir machen das
richtig ein
übertreibt bitte dich mach das bitte
nicht nach wir trinken jetzt auch nicht
allzu viel wir trinken soviel dass wir
in lustigen pegel erreichen
euro aber wir übertreiben es halt nicht
mal das einfach ungesund ist und
ich würde keinen bei uns werden die
folgen auf jeden fall musste gestalten
und was ich muss dann gleich einfach
einen kleinen kann weder bis leicht das
ist es
okay
hosentaschen habe ich nicht ich hab
männerhosen
zu einer fantastischen neuen folge drei
cocktails
[Musik]
freddy du hast dein einsatz verpasst und
ihr wisst nur eine kann germany's next
topmodel werden
drei kfd
danke
mögen so gebohrt läuft dieses mal
vieles ist passiert krone hat uns
auseinander getrieben und heute habe ich
meine periode bekommen also es wird eine
spannende folge ich bin mittendrin in
den weg es hat sich nichts verändert
ja also mich entschieden ich bin jetzt
ich hab' ich habe gesehen wo die gesagt
hat wisst ihr was ihren style gehabt
haben
aber nur weil ich dazu sagen da passt
die schublade thema schublade ich mache
ich manchmal den bogen rum also zwei
jahre corona finden hat sich verändert
ja meine tage ja aber was hat sich dein
ganz besonders verändert in diesen zwei
jahren man geht nicht mehr in den
supermarkt
[Musik]
aber manchmal auch nicht weil es gibt
neue service godzilla
alea klar also nach dann könnt ihr euch
noch gerne melden und vielleicht dieses
video sponsern oder nächstes video auf
jeden fall gibt es auch anderswo stellen
habe ich kann man daraufhin kommt
eingeben
mindestens zehn euro zu die machen wir
das heute wir werden uns jetzt zutaten
bestellen wir gehen nicht in den
supermarkt und hu dann machen wir die
cocktails ich weiß nicht ob wir eine
gemeinsame zutaten brauchen ein fahrrad
um was geht es denn jetzt inhaltlich und
dann wieder runter und dann ist wenn ich
jedoch endlich ist das mein sekunde da
ja das ist ja also inhaltlich geht es
darum eingelieferten cocktail zu
bekommen du hast nichts im haus du
bekommst gäste dass wir jetzt bei
shopping queens ist jetzt so das
szenario noch mal siehst du ja und nein
rasch wurde angefragt
auch gehört
zur unterschrieben
ja weil nur leute dabei haben die
wirklich bock darauf
mich halt mich wenn ich hab dir mal ein
video gesehen tschechien meine preis was
los
das ist nicht mal meiner mutter zuliebe
gemacht jetzt also wenn es mir auch
schon zu wenig geld ach ja ich habe
meine mutter auch mal nicht mehr gesehen
einmal geredet ja ich dachte man dass
meine mama getroffen ach so wir haben
den garten umgebaut und ssds für einen
schuh
ja eine gemeinsame zutat meintest du
immer ein thema deine freundin hat ihre
periode sie möchte aber gern einen
cocktail trinken du musst dir einen
cocktail machen der ihr richtig gut
schmeckt und da ihr die schmerzen weg
macht und sie trotzdem ihre qualvollen
periode nach dem verbot will
kann bei drei perioden cocktails
ich bin ich mich einmal kurz nach frucht
cocktail zu machen weil sie sofort bei
periode versteht es vielmehr als
fruchtbar nein ich bin sehr fruchtbar
konnten danach noch alles ist also um
einen fruchtigen cocktail der geliefert
wurden musste freut sich schmecken haben
uns dennoch frucht beinhalten frucht
beinhalten würde ich mich ja schwer bei
solchen themen drogen
ich habe da gar nicht drüber nachgedacht
ohne hat uns wirklich einen strich durch
die pop up gruppe von anlagen überhaupt
nicht darüber nachgedacht heute ist das
sogar ein festes konzept und wir finden
dass der plan stand krass wir hätten
eine papa gehabt
august wird wieder ist aber dass wir
noch am anfang von corinna da haben wir
noch voll viele live streams und so
zusammen gemacht haben wir noch eine
menge crossing gespielt von
ich habe ja nachdem ich erst mal auf
radio belly habt ihr mich ausgeschlossen
und danach aus euren erdbeertorte krieg
auch in sachen hab nämlich
ausgeschlossen und dann habe ich mich
mit ihm befreundet
dazu hat noch jemand an mich gedacht
haben beim dreißigsten zeug in deinem
video und in deinem video und in meinem
video was jetzt
[Musik]
was mir schlimmer er weiß ja auch nicht
wie eine geheime geburtstagsüberraschung
planen nein ich bin nicht nachtragend
ich werde euch gewinne
sagen wir jedes mal das stimmt
eigentlich sage ich das immer irgendwann
mal und ja du probierst uns dann immer
wieder zu ersetzen wie immer
konnte die hundeschule holt eure handys
raus öffnet die app eurer wahl und
feststellt bestellt wie will
[Musik]
drei monate später geht es jetzt auch
los die bestellungen sind angekommen
freddy du was als erstes danach kam 1
und dann kelly ja
möchte ich nicht raten aufweisen
du siehst mich hassen unsere zutaten
vorstellen so ja warte dann meistens
sowie die zuschauer das rad schon
genossen haben
ich habe toni kreide absoluter wäre das
hier das ist schon johnny blond und
lemonade noch das letzte mittel
ich wusste nicht dass der whisky drin
ist dass wir nun eine limo zu mischen
neben cocktails getestet ja aber
erst mal meinen geburtstag
wir haben einmal schön eingepackt in rom
mit leder ich habe mein geld können wir
das noch nicht zurück bekommen also ist
es bis dato meiner dann habe ich in
alter manier weil heute sowieso
frei sind wir zum arzt gehen nicht so
ganz hin welche jetzt schon drei
verschiedene
aber du musst auch manchmal den
fleißigsten ebenso viele tipps sie baten
die tänzer dann habe ich so eine rote
brad pitt dann habe ich noch eine glaube
ich das gleiche dann habe ich das hier
noch ein bisschen rot und danach
ausgetragen weil es geht ja auch so ein
bisschen um dieses fruchtbare dass man
vielleicht seine periode hat und dann
wieder zu kräften kommen muss aber auch
ein bisschen abgelenkt werden muss das
ist ganz gerne so beckens krankls da
oben drauf aber ich glaube das könnte
das geil sein
also ich find sie brauchen und fährt nun
faires thema für mich bin ich ganz schön
war und wer dennoch ein ich werde nie
fruchtbar seiten dort vielleicht
verbucht wer
du bist gerade groß angekündigte star
einen tag bekommen muss ja und ja bist
du gerade zu bilden ja da bin ich immer
denken wenn ich meine tage bekommen ob
sage ich dass
gerade darüber reden erst ihren becken
ein klarer ist rohen becken und da habe
ich ihr letztes mal von abgeraten weil
du auch die von dir abgeguckt engländer
die games engländer ja ich bin so
vermittle
war sparen ja sein dass engländer der
durch den vater der rockstar ist
[Musik]
ich nehme diese sagen ja mit dem party
girls musste ich dann als lebens und ich
liebe dich
lieb
ich habe blut orangen gefunden das sind
und ich habe gedacht ich habe drei
blutorangen gekauft ich habe leider
am tag drei
periode die erdbeer woche erdbeer woche
ist das eher vanille
traumjob
[Musik]
dekanate wandel ohne alle beeren sind
ausgebucht
diese drei
panels sogar
heidelberg
mit einem ruhigen tag wie
er ist
die liebe bis sich ein scheiß ernst du
kommst im dieses büro
stellt vor ich wusste niemand
also ich hab's gekauft auch philipp
petzschner hier ist der film bei dem was
du letzten doch etwas aufgenommen
neu definieren münchen videos das
probiere hat das geld
nicht funktioniert schade dass wir
gerade ist
[Musik]
drachen von zitronen schälchen apfel
nur draußen aber dem 5 1 vom zitrone
und danach nie per 31
und wird
rotwein
ich halte es gibt ja immer was regionale
zum kaufen kann ein bisschen regional
eines auf was ist mir erst mal
[Gelächter]
raus um
familie
resch kalorien ab und mit vitamin b6
ohne package das für park doch es wird
habe d c und zink und system one
hatte sehr viel
cash group post gaben je
zwei jahre hatten sie zeit um sich zu
entwickeln was ist das
[Applaus]
gefährlich also wieso guckt er so ich
verstehst du hast kaugummis geholt ja
und bei mundgeruch oder was willst du
sagen willst du ja nicht hinkommt wie
das geht
erklärt mache am ende gute leute
dann hat er nicht so naiv sein ja das
war deine tage ist das haben wir heute
noch nicht thematisiert
aber vielleicht sage ich jetzt mal an
der stelle ich habe meine tage
sieht das euro pro person
kannst du das einfach diese kenne so
lieb wie milch ab sucht so ein packendes
unser päckchen abkühlen was anderes
abgezogen
[Musik]
hier ist wieder eine lieblingsgruppe ja
ich stelle mir erst mal einen neuen
richtig an welchen er freut sich schon
heute ein und damit würde ich sagen
die durch spiele
dem 30
[Musik]
also ist es
ist eine chance besser du machst so viel
länger koch
aber ich bin immer dankbar
dass wir selber spaß
komplett eigene welt in
sachen auf nämlich ausgeschlossen
[Gelächter]
schön ist
die blutorange blutet wirklich kann sein
dass sie da von ihnen den namen haben ok
ich muss erst mal kurz überlegen ich
starte schon wieder viel zu
hastig das ist neu das kenne ich nicht
küchenkrepp
scheiße
ich wollte
einmal sein doch keiner guckt jetzt den
ball am volk nicht vor es probieren
veröffentlich früchte von jörg david
kelley hatten viel zu grosses mass an
der hand
das ist die richtige
das ist so nein doch sei die macht es
nicht selber dann nimmt das nicht so
[Musik]
was verändern leute aber wir probieren
alle so dass es krampfhaft sich
verändert aber es ist genauso wir
ja also ich hab dann auch viele jetzt
mit sport gemacht
wiederzugeben nicht auch in einer festen
partnerschaft
was glaubt ihr warum war unsere
freundschaft so fragil dass ein virus
gekommen ist und wir nicht mehr
miteinander geredet habe wir hatten eine
verdammt schwierige nacht sein gemeinsam
und ich weiß das ging auch gut in die
psyche seien deswegen müssen wir uns
wieder bisher offen ich würde glaube ich
sagen ich habe dass das erdbeer toten
links persönlich genommen
alles nichts
die gute in diesem video hört sich
schlimmer mein gott ich habe das sehr
lustiges gerade
[Gelächter]
du kommst du den platz auf
karin räumen klasse auch die haustiere
ist nichts geworden
ich bin jetzt fertig ich habe schon
meine kleinen donuts ihr verteilt die
erst in die app er wochen donuts er ich
glaube da darf man einfach mal so jetzt
reinbeißen oder weil wir es uns verdient
haben
findet auch ein profi was sowas angeht
waren essen nehmen ja so thon der jumbo
schreiner ist
[Musik]
raus
so
denkt sich vanessa auch
wer möchte anfangen du hast doch schon
130 dollar zu essen dass unter den
hammer raus ja aber nein immer muss
sagen caddies sieht optisch wirklich
fantastisch aus sollen wir hier
das würde ja so ein cocktail heißt david
penetration ihr könnt euch da bin ich
jetzt schon sagen er ist halt ein
sinnbild der fruchtbarkeit
ja da ist so ein kleiner im schlaf wie
becky drin und dann einmal zum trinken
war es dabei um es auch ein bisschen
becken gesprenkelt um den schutz
ich das war was das namensvorschlag ich
möchte noch mal kurz hier die ja und ja
probiert doch einfach mal
wenn du willst kannst du auch angenommen
werden
es gibt tatsächlich viele cocktails wo
man welt nämlich obendrauf sprenkel denn
so klein stück ist tatsächlich so einen
komischen russischen bakip war die ganze
zeit da würden wir nicht
also ich finde der schmeckt sehr nach
himbeere sehr hellhörig am ende liegt
daran weil höhere drin ist so ein
bisschen von dem becken allerdings die
kombination ist absolut geil ich zum
beispiel gar nicht weil du hast dieses
seitige vom becken und wird sofort
dieses säure süße da hinterher sodass
liegt noch auf der grapefruit damit
schon ein bisschen sauer kaltenberg habe
ich mir ausgedacht habe wirklich nicht
mein plan b also ist wirklich also damit
rechnen dass ist das was man natürlich
an solchen tagen haben möchte ja wenn es
einem dann gut geht ne zu sagen also das
möchte ich haben
die drei
daraus gezogen
seht ihr an den budgets und glas da ist
so so zeugt ja so dass ist symbolisiert
die toilette
gott
habe täglich alle dann haben wir diesen
kleinen lebt das ist tatsächlich der
slip also die binde kann man es auch
nennen pflegen was man da so als trink
und wie sie unschwer erkennen können
sind die blutorange aus wie eine kleine
für jay jay betrieb man das denn das ist
das soll man trinkt das jetzt so und was
macht man mit dem dort runter dass man
natürlich kann man essen
er schmeckt wie kalter sangria
andrea ist jetzt auch selten waren bin
ich auch ehrlich
tatsächlich
es hat einen vorteil weil ich mag
sangria
aber es auch nach teil 1 teil was ein
neuer ist so ne und der rest ist halt
irgendwie so toiletten schloss
paletten schlotter aus der
auch ein guter folgen titel man also
schmeckt schon wie eine sangría das
stimmt
ist bis ins andrea weiß mit jeder weiß
was wir machen müssen eigentlich dabei
machen wir ab nächster folge wir müssen
mal einen preis dafür beziffern wie viel
für wie viel wir die verticken würden ja
ich bin immer interessant ich sage ich
bin auch wieder einmal in der
bastelarbeiten bisschen verloren
gegangen mal wandert immer dann ist ja
aber eine person die hier noch viel
gebastelt hat also erstens mal wie ihr
euch schon aufgefallen ist ist man drin
klaus stark
hängt einfach damals distanz lange sogar
das ist ganz schlimm dass in binden
werbung im fernsehen
die rot geworden ist sondern immer eine
blaue flüssigkeit des handels geändert
oder man hat sich nicht ewig hält da
haben wir schon so eine medizin artigen
behälter erstellt die tabletten dar die
man nehmen kann zb über profibus coop
ankläger immer sachen die wir bisschen
helfen uns wirklich nicht mehr geht hier
doch und mach dich so wie alt dieser
einzelnen die nasen spermien und das
hier ist das befruchtet sind dann würde
er auch so eine befristete
natürlich viele nährstoffe und vitamine
weekend alles schon ein bisschen rot
habe ich zuerst also also wie man das
bringt alle einen kaugummi in den mund
und dann nimmt er einen schluck muss man
das kaum davor mich ja bundestag roma zu
entfalten aber einmal einmal einkaufen
und das ist vitamin bundesbürger
sowohl möglichen schluck ist
gesund denn ich habe es eilig den sack
mit der kombination mit dem kaugummi
noch drin das ist das wasser
abgelassen betritt man das nicht aber
ich stelle mir noch keinen scheiß
kaugummi im mund und trinkt
der ferieneffekt kaum genau machst du
keinen kaufen gerade
meine neuen zähne sind noch nicht
eingetroffen mit dem kleber
was verfolger das geld ich bin einfach
ich sags ja auch so also ohne das fand
ich es auch sehr lecker okay auch vor
allem mit der passion fruit mit diesen
kleinen sauren stückchen mit den kernen
sogar erstaunlich becker gewesen dafür
dass du so rum geholt hat
das war es richtig die socken ich habe
ganz vorn sind die klassenarbeit hier zu
zwei grad genau
diese drei zwei eins zu sagen wer
gewonnen hat 321
[Musik]
aber die präsenz ihre helden und ein
bild gemacht haben
[Musik]
und hier kommt dein preis bitte kopf
nach
die hat uns waren ein ticker gesehen wo
ich ein cockpit im ungleichen hier ist
[Musik]
ja das möchte kelly haben jegliche
aktionen hier passieren damit habe ich
nichts mehr zu tun für sofort sagen
[Gelächter]
dass man es nicht macht
dann richtig wohl nur die klinik belangt
werden dass das nochmal passiert
herrlich
komischer abend
klassentreffen war so komisch eingang
wartet
machte zuerst einmal ich ein bisschen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
das wort immer
gut gemacht genauso
viel zu wenig die andere
für dich langsam an seine siege serie
comedy du weißt auch das ist willst die
drei von der tankstelle sind wieder da
leute schreibt in die kommentare wenn
ihr neue ideen habt ihr drei kommt der
ist sie bald treffen sich regelmäßig
außer es kommt noch mal eine neue panda
aber bis dahin in der werkstatt ja und
so lange hält auf unsere freundschaft
ist ja